This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In The Gift of the Magi, a short story written by O. Henry and published in 1905, a young husband and wife each struggle privately with a dilemma. Christmas is coming and neither has enough money to buy the other a gift. Della has only $1.87 saved up. Jim has almost nothing. You probably know how the story turns out. Della sells her beautiful long hair in order to buy Jim a fine chain for his watch,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在欧·亨利于1905年发表的短篇小说《麦琪的礼物》中，一对年轻夫妇各自私下里陷入了困境。圣诞节快到了，两人都没有足够的钱给对方买礼物。黛拉只攒了1.87美元。吉姆几乎一无所有。你可能知道故事的结局。黛拉卖掉了她美丽的秀发，为吉姆的怀表买了一条精致的表链，
the most valuable thing he owns. Meanwhile, Jim sells his watch to pay for a set of expensive combs for Della's hair. Each gift negates the other. At the end of the story, O. Henry writes, the Magi, as you know, were wise men, wonderfully wise men, who brought gifts to the babe in the manger. They invented the art of giving Christmas presents. Being wise, their gifts were no doubt wise ones,
那是他最珍贵的东西。与此同时，吉姆卖掉了他的怀表，为黛拉买了一套昂贵的发梳。每一份礼物都抵消了另一份的价值。在故事的结尾，欧·亨利写道，麦琪，如你所知，是智者，非常聪明的智者，他们给马槽里的圣婴送去了礼物。他们发明了赠送圣诞礼物的艺术。由于他们是智者，他们的礼物无疑也是明智的，
possibly bearing the privilege of exchange in case of duplication. And here I have lamely related to you the uneventful chronicle of two foolish children in a flat, who most unwisely sacrificed for each other the greatest treasures of their house. But in a last word to the wise of these days, let it be said that of all who give gifts, these too were the wisest. Of all who give and receive gifts, such as they, are the wisest. Everywhere they are wisest. They are the magi.
如果礼物重复了，或许还附带了交换的特权。在这里，我笨拙地向你讲述了两个住在公寓里的傻孩子平淡无奇的故事，他们极其不明智地为对方牺牲了家里最宝贵的财富。但对于当今的智者，最后还要说一句，在所有赠送礼物的人中，他们是最聪明的。在所有赠送和接受礼物的人中，像他们这样的人是最聪明的。无论在哪里，他们都是最聪明的。他们就是麦琪。
In other words, it's the thought that counts. That's a sweet idea, but is it true? Today on the show, modern psychology takes on an ancient problem. Gifts and gift-giving are as old as humanity itself. Over the centuries, humans have used gifts to express love, offer admiration, and obtain favors. New research identifies why the presents we offer for birthdays and holidays often miss their mark. How to become a better gift giver, this week on Hidden Brain. All of us know what it's like to get a great gift, the kind we receive with pleasure and that we remember for a long, long time afterwards.
换句话说，心意最重要。这是一个甜蜜的想法，但它是真的吗？今天在节目中，现代心理学将探讨一个古老的问题。礼物和赠礼行为与人类本身一样古老。几个世纪以来，人类一直用礼物来表达爱意、表示钦佩和获取恩惠。新的研究揭示了为什么我们在生日和节日送出的礼物往往不尽如人意。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨如何成为一个更好的送礼者。我们都知道收到一份好礼物是什么感觉，那种我们欣然接受，并在很久很久之后依然记忆犹新的礼物。
All of us also remember, well, the other kind of gift, the board game that doesn't interest us, the dashed off last minute bauble, the inappropriate item of clothing. At Carnegie Mellon University, Jeff Gallick has spent a lot of time thinking about gifts and gift-giving. He has learned a lot about bad gifts. Jeff Gallick, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Jeff, I understand that growing up as an American with Jewish-Ukrainian roots, your family put on a big celebration on New Year's Day every year.
我们也同样记得，嗯，另一种礼物，比如我们不感兴趣的棋盘游戏，匆忙买来的廉价小玩意，或者不合适的衣服。在卡内基梅隆大学，杰夫·加利克花了很多时间思考礼物和赠礼行为。他学到了很多关于糟糕礼物的知识。杰夫·加利克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。杰夫，我了解到你作为一个有犹太-乌克兰血统的美国人，你的家庭每年元旦都会举行盛大的庆祝活动。
Can you tell me what that gathering was like when you were a small child? So we had this tradition where our immediate family as well as some close friends would all gather. And there was a tradition of exchanging gifts. These were typically not your major Christmas-sized gifts, but something minimal that would just kind of fulfill the needs that people have for this kind of gift-giving exchange. That was basically the nature of it.
你能告诉我当你还是个小孩子时，那种聚会是什么样的吗？我们有一个传统，直系亲属和一些亲密朋友都会聚在一起。还有一个交换礼物的传统。这些通常不是那种大型的圣诞礼物，而是某种微小的东西，只是为了满足人们对这种交换礼物的需求。这基本上就是它的本质。
Got it. So you were around 10 years old at the time. And on one of these occasions, you were presented with a New Year's gift by one of your relatives. What was the gift? And paint a picture for me of the moment when you received it. Yeah, so I'm roughly 10 years old. And as you can imagine, as a child, receiving gifts
明白了。所以你当时大约10岁。在其中一次聚会上，你的一位亲戚送了你一份新年礼物。那是什么礼物？请为我描绘一下你收到它时的情景。是的，我当时大约10岁。正如你可以想象的那样，作为一个孩子，收到礼物
is a lot of fun, right? And getting new things is always joyous. And everybody's going around handing out their gifts one at a time. And I do remember distinctly this family member. This was a distant family member giving me a pretty large item, which is already exciting. We tend to think large items are going is already exciting.
是一件非常有趣的事情，对吧？得到新东西总是令人高兴的。每个人都在轮流分发礼物。我清楚地记得这位家庭成员。这是一位远房亲戚，他给了我一件相当大的物品，这已经让人很兴奋了。我们往往认为大件物品会让人兴奋。
And upon unwrapping it, I found that it was a tin of popped popcorn. And I had absolutely no idea what to do with this. I mean, it was just the biggest letdown. As a kid you want toys or candy or something that's going to make you have a lot of fun. And a tin of popcorn, it was just not anything remotely what I was expecting. So to say I was disappointed is probably an understatement. I think I was a polite child and I said, thank you. And we moved on with our evening. But yeah, it was not exactly the perfect gift.
拆开包装后，我发现那是一罐爆米花。我完全不知道该拿它怎么办。我的意思是，这简直是最大的失望。作为一个孩子，你想要玩具、糖果或者能让你玩得很开心的东西。而一罐爆米花，根本不是我所期待的。所以说我感到失望可能还是轻描淡写的。我想我是一个有礼貌的孩子，我说，谢谢。然后我们继续度过了那个晚上。但确实，它算不上完美的礼物。
I understand another time you got a key chain from some Caribbean island is one of these gifts. That's right. It was a keychain that somebody picked up as a souvenir on some Caribbean adventure. And it was given to me in this New Year's context exchange, which just doesn't make any sense. I wasn't at that island. I was a 10-year-old who doesn't have any keys. I had no idea what I was supposed to be doing with this. But again, you say politely thank you and move on with the evening. So I understand that researchers have studied the effects that bad gifts have on receivers.
我了解到还有一次你从某个加勒比岛屿收到一个钥匙扣作为礼物。没错。那是一个别人在加勒比探险时买的纪念品钥匙扣。它是在这种新年交换礼物的场合给我的，这根本说不通。我没去过那个岛。我是一个10岁的孩子，没有任何钥匙。我完全不知道该拿它做什么。但同样，你礼貌地说声谢谢，然后继续度过那个晚上。所以我了解到研究人员已经研究了糟糕礼物对接收者产生的影响。
When you receive that tub of popcorn from your relative, how did it make you feel towards the gift giver? Yeah. I mean, admittedly as a child, I think my feelings were pretty thin. I don't think I had too many deep thoughts at that moment, but you can imagine very easily that when you receive a bad gift, what it shows is that somebody's not very thoughtful, right? They haven't considered what the recipient's experience
当你从亲戚那里收到那桶爆米花时，它让你对送礼者有什么感觉？是的。说实话，作为一个孩子，我想我的感受比较肤浅。我不认为在那一刻我有太多深刻的想法，但你可以很容易地想象，当你收到一份糟糕的礼物时，它表明某人并不是很体贴，对吧？他们没有考虑接收者的体验
is gonna be like. I was pretty disappointed as a kid. Kids get over things quickly, and so I moved on with my life, but there's a version where that relationship isn't really benefited at all. And if anything, there's some real harm done, right? It's a signal that
会是什么样。作为一个孩子，我感到非常失望。孩子们很快就会从事情中走出来，所以我继续我的生活，但有一种情况是，这种关系并没有真正受益。如果说有什么影响的话，那就是造成了一些真正的伤害，对吧？这是一种信号，表明
you're not treating the person with respect and thoughtfulness. Now, a bad gift or a gift from someone you don't particularly like leaves you with some obligation to reciprocate. So now you don't just have a bad gift, you're left with the obligation to respond. Can you talk a moment about the role that obligation plays in gift giving and the effect it has on the relationships between people? Yeah, obligations are probably the single biggest reason that gifts are given in the first place,
你没有以尊重和体贴的态度对待那个人。现在，一份糟糕的礼物或来自你不特别喜欢的人的礼物，会让你有回礼的义务。所以现在你不仅得到了一份糟糕的礼物，还留下了回应的义务。你能谈谈义务在赠礼中扮演的角色以及它对人际关系的影响吗？是的，义务可能是人们赠送礼物最主要的原因，
for Christmas or for a birthday or an anniversary or a graduation. And when you get a gift, it feels like you absolutely have to return that gesture at an appropriate moment. It could be in that same gift exchange if it's a holiday season, or it might just be the next birthday that comes up for that person.
无论是为了圣诞节、生日、周年纪念日还是毕业典礼。当你收到一份礼物时，你会觉得必须在适当的时候回报这种姿态。如果是在节日期间，可能是在同一次礼物交换中，或者可能只是对方的下一个生日。
And so doubling down on you received a bad gift, you don't feel connected to that person at all because they've shown that they're not thoughtful, and now you have the burden of actually going out and getting them a gift, somebody who you probably don't care about, that's a big problem. There's been some work looking at how bad gifts carry more than just psychological costs they also carry economic costs. Back in 1993 the economist Joel Walfogel published a famous paper called the Deadweight Loss of Christmas. What was the paper about
所以，当你收到一份糟糕的礼物时，你会觉得与那个人完全没有联系，因为他们表现得并不体贴，而现在你却背负着必须去给他们买礼物的负担，对于一个你可能并不在乎的人，这是一个大问题。有一些研究探讨了糟糕的礼物不仅带来心理成本，还带来经济成本。早在1993年，经济学家乔尔·沃尔福格尔发表了一篇著名的论文，题为《圣诞节的无谓损失》。这篇论文是关于什么的，
Jeff? Sure it's a wonderful title too right it's oblique but the paper basically says that if I have $100 and I spend it on myself, the chance that I get myself something that's truly worth $100 to me is very high because I know my own preferences, right? I know what it is that I want, I know what would make me happy.
杰夫？当然，这也是一个很棒的标题，对吧？它很隐晦，但论文基本上说，如果我有100美元，我把它花在自己身上，我买到对自己真正价值100美元的东西的可能性非常高，因为我知道自己的偏好，对吧？我知道我想要什么，我知道什么会让我快乐。
But if you, Shankar, are gonna get me a gift for that same price point, the chances of that matching my preferences are much lower because, well, you're not me. And so the likelihood that you're going to be able to, you know, drill into my head and figure out exactly what's going to make me happy is smaller. So there's a loss. But the utility is lower for me as the recipient because I'm getting something that's less enjoyable. Joel Wolfogel concluded in his paper that, quote, It's likely that receiving a gift will leave the recipient worse off than if she had made her own consumption choice with an equal amount of cash. I find that holiday gift giving destroys between 10% and a third of the value of gifts.
但如果你，尚卡尔，要以同样的价格给我买一份礼物，它符合我偏好的可能性要低得多，因为，嗯，你不是我。所以你能够钻进我的脑子里，弄清楚到底什么会让我快乐的可能性更小。所以存在一种损失。作为接收者，我的效用更低，因为我得到的东西没那么令人愉快。乔尔·沃尔福格尔在论文中总结道：“收到礼物很可能让接收者比自己用等额现金进行消费选择时的情况更糟。”我发现节日送礼摧毁了礼物价值的10%到三分之一。
I asked Jeff if his experiences with bad gifts and the obligations they brought with them made him less inclined to be part of the gift giving economy. Maybe this is a broader conversation, but I feel like gift giving as an enterprise in our society is really problematic. Right? You think about the burden that it places on gift givers in terms of financial expenses, but they feel obligated to. They feel like they have to engage in this activity even if it comes at the expense of their own financial well-being. And so it's very hard to justify these expenses. And yeah, I mean, I think to answer your question, I do often question my own involvement in the gift giving exchange. Do you believe that it's time to stop giving gifts altogether?
我问杰夫，他关于糟糕礼物的经历以及随之而来的义务是否让他不太愿意参与赠礼经济。也许这是一个更广泛的对话，但我感觉赠礼作为我们社会的一项事业确实存在问题。对吧？你考虑到它给送礼者带来的经济负担，但他们感到有义务这样做。他们觉得即使以牺牲自己的财务状况为代价，也必须参与这项活动。所以很难证明这些支出的合理性。是的，我想回答你的问题，我确实经常质疑自己对礼物交换的参与。你认为现在是完全停止赠送礼物的时候了吗？
I think it's time for us to rethink the way that we give gifts. When we come back, a better way forward, understanding how to become a better gift-giver. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When big holidays roll around, many of us find ourselves awash in bad gifts. We may smile and say thank you, but inside we ask, what made you think I would want something so hideous?
我认为是我们重新思考赠礼方式的时候了。回来后，我们将探讨更好的前进方向，了解如何成为一个更好的送礼者。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当重大节日来临时，我们许多人发现自己被糟糕的礼物淹没了。我们可能会微笑并说谢谢，但内心却在问，是什么让你觉得我会想要这么丑的东西？
At Carnegie Mellon University, Jeff Gallag studies the psychology of gift giving. Jeff, many of us dream of giving the perfect gift, something that is surprising and meaningful that sends the recipient over the moon. I want to play you a clip of what the perfect gift-giving moment looks like in our fantasies. This is from the TV show, The Big Bang Theory, where the character Penny, who works as a waitress at a restaurant, gives her neighbor Sheldon, who's a theoretical physicist
在卡内基梅隆大学，杰夫·加利克研究赠礼心理学。杰夫，我们许多人梦想送出完美的礼物，那种令人惊喜且有意义的礼物，能让接收者欣喜若狂。我想给你播放一段我们幻想中完美赠礼时刻的片段。这是来自电视剧《生活大爆炸》，剧中角色佩妮在一家餐厅当服务员，她送给邻居谢尔顿——一位理论物理学家
and a huge Star Trek fan, a most unusual present. Here. Oh, a napkin. Turn it over. To Sheldon, live long and prosper, Leonard Nimoy. He came into the restaurant, sorry the napkin's dirty, he wiped his mouth with it. I possess the DNA of Leonard Nimoy. So acquiring the DNA of Mr. Spock himself earned Penny the reaction we all look for when we give gifts.
和《星际迷航》的超级粉丝——一份非常不寻常的礼物。给你。哦，一张餐巾纸。翻过来。致谢尔顿，生生不息，繁荣昌盛，伦纳德·尼莫伊。他来到餐厅，抱歉餐巾纸脏了，他用它擦了嘴。我拥有伦纳德·尼莫伊的DNA。所以，获得史波克先生本人的DNA为佩妮赢得了我们送礼时都期待的反应。
In reality, of course, things usually don't turn out like this. Jeff, you've studied how and why gift giving goes wrong. And one significant cause of bad gifts is that gift givers and gift receivers are focused on entirely different timeframes. What are gift givers focused on? Gift givers overwhelmingly are focused on that moment of exchange. So in the clip that you just played, that moment that Sheldon opens up the gift and sees that it's from Leonard Nimoy, that is what gift givers are trying to optimize on.
在现实中，当然，事情通常不会这样发展。杰夫，你研究过赠礼是如何以及为什么会出错的。糟糕礼物的一个重要原因是送礼者和接收者关注的时间框架完全不同。送礼者关注的是什么？送礼者绝大多数关注的是交换的那一刻。所以，在你刚才播放的片段中，谢尔顿打开礼物并看到它来自伦纳德·尼莫伊的那一刻，就是送礼者试图优化的目标。
They're trying to say, how can I put the biggest smile on someone's face the moment that they open the gift and realize what it is that they have? So what are recipients focused on? To some extent, they're focused on that as well, but to a greater extent, they're also thinking about the experience of that gift over the ownership of the gift. So when you receive something in the moment,
他们试图说，我怎样才能在对方打开礼物并意识到它是什么的那一刻，让对方脸上露出最大的笑容？那么接收者关注的是什么呢？在某种程度上，他们也关注这一点，但在更大程度上，他们也在考虑拥有这份礼物的体验。所以当你在那一刻收到某样东西时，
it might make you happy, but does it actually provide you value and utility and joy for the duration of owning whatever it is that you've received? And sometimes the things that bring you happiness in the moment are not the things that bring you happiness in the long term. So this fundamental difference in priorities, a focus on the immediate and the short term versus a focus on the long term, produces other mismatches. Tell us about the surprise factor, Jeff. The surprise is something that gift giversivers think is critical to a recipient.
它可能会让你快乐，但它是否真的在你拥有它的整个期间为你提供了价值、效用和快乐？有时那些让你瞬间快乐的东西，并不是那些能让你长期快乐的东西。因此，这种优先级的根本差异，即对即时和短期的关注与对长期的关注，产生了其他不匹配。杰夫，告诉我们关于惊喜因素的事。惊喜是送礼者认为对接收者至关重要的东西。
Right? So when I give you a gift, I have this belief that you will only value that gift if you don't expect receiving it. And over and over again, we find that that is just not true. If you think about a choice that a gift-giver has, they can either give something that they're pretty sure is going to be a successful gift. It's something that they know that the recipient is going to receive well, because maybe they've told them in the past they like that category of products. But that's not surprising, right?
对吧？所以当我给你一份礼物时，我有一种信念，即只有在你没预料到会收到它时，你才会珍视这份礼物。但我们一次又一次地发现，事实并非如此。如果你考虑送礼者的一个选择，他们要么送出他们相当确定会成功的礼物。这是他们知道接收者会喜欢的东西，因为也许他们过去告诉过他们喜欢那类产品。但这并不令人惊讶，对吧？
If I tell you that I like baseball cards and you get me a pack of baseball cards, I mean, that's great, but, you know, I knew that you were going to get that for me because I've already expressed that preference. And so as a giver, you're reluctant to do that because it minimizes on some of that surprisingness. And so givers tend to think that, you know, making that surprising gesture is what drives a good gift. And that's just not true. Givers also seem to care a lot about how a gift is presented. Do recipients care as much?
如果我告诉你我喜欢棒球卡，你给我买了一包棒球卡，我的意思是，那很好，但是，你知道，我知道你会给我买那个，因为我已经表达了那个偏好。所以作为送礼者，你不愿意这样做，因为它减少了一些惊喜感。因此，送礼者倾向于认为，做出那种令人惊喜的姿态才是好礼物的驱动力。但这根本不是真的。送礼者似乎也非常关心礼物的包装方式。接收者也同样关心吗？
Again, to a much lesser extent. Certainly beautiful wrapping paper and a beautiful packaging will affect the immediate, but those get thrown out two seconds after somebody opens a gift. And so they're really not providing any long-term value. So it looks like gift seekers are seeking this wow factor. They care about the moment the gift is given, the surprise it produces, the reaction it elicits. Can you talk about the idea that one consequence of this has to do with our propensity to give gifts that are unusual, dramatic, and luxurious?
同样，程度要小得多。当然，漂亮的包装纸和精美的包装会影响即时的感受，但那些在某人打开礼物两秒钟后就被扔掉了。所以它们并没有提供任何长期价值。所以看起来送礼者在追求这种“哇”的因素。他们关心礼物送出的那一刻，它产生的惊喜，它引发的反应。你能谈谈这种后果之一与我们倾向于赠送不寻常、戏剧性和奢华礼物的倾向有关吗？
This often plays out in things like wedding registries. So you have a couple getting married. They probably very thoughtfully consider the items that they need to start their life together. They put that information out there. They tell you, here are the things we want from the stores that we want them. And then somebody goes off registry and buys them some random junk that they have no need for because somehow that's going to be seen
这通常体现在婚礼登记等事情上。所以你有一对要结婚的夫妇。他们可能非常深思熟虑地考虑了他们开始共同生活所需的物品。他们把这些信息发布出来。他们告诉你，这是我们想要的商店里的东西。然后有人不按登记清单买，给他们买了一些他们根本不需要的随机垃圾，因为不知何故这会被视为
as more surprising and more special. And it's just so counter to what the couple is actually asking for. Well, one of your co-authors once wrote a paper title, Sometimes It's Okay to Give a Blender. That's right. And I take it that recipients in general care less about the unusual and the glamorous. Again, it's not that they don't care about it at all, of course, but if it's glamorous but it doesn't actually serve
更令人惊喜、更特别。但这与这对夫妇实际要求的完全背道而驰。嗯，你的合著者之一曾经写过一篇论文，标题是《有时送搅拌机是可以的》。没错。我认为接收者通常不太关心不寻常和华丽的东西。同样，并不是说他们一点也不关心，当然，但如果它很华丽但实际上并没有为某人服务
a purpose for someone, it's almost like a white elephant gift, like it's more of a burden than anything else. So isn't it interesting, Jeff, that in popular culture when we have these gift-giving exchanges, givers often want to be seen as creative. Can you talk a little bit about this, that part of the motivation of the gift giver is to be seen as a creative gift giver? So this kind of speaks to the motivations that people have for giving gifts in the first place.
一个目的，它几乎就像一份“白象”礼物，与其说它是礼物，不如说它更像是一种负担。那么杰夫，有趣的是，在流行文化中，当我们进行这些礼物交换时，送礼者往往希望被视为有创意。你能谈谈这一点吗，即送礼者的部分动机是希望被视为有创意的送礼者？所以这在某种程度上说明了人们最初赠送礼物的动机。
I think a lot of people imagine that the reason gifts are exchanged is because we're trying to make other people happy. So if I give you a gift, I hope you have a joyous experience with it. And that's certainly part of the reason gifts are exchanged is because we're trying to make other people happy. So if I give you a gift, I hope you have a joyous experience with it. And that's certainly part of the reason. But there are also very selfish reasons for giving a gift. One of them is about signaling who you are as a person and who you are as a gift giver, both to yourself and to everybody around. And so signaling that you're a creative gift giver is important because if I think I'm
我想很多人想象礼物交换的原因是因为我们试图让别人快乐。所以如果我给你一份礼物，我希望你从中获得快乐的体验。这当然是礼物交换的部分原因，因为我们试图让别人快乐。所以如果我给你一份礼物，我希望你从中获得快乐的体验。这当然是部分原因。但赠送礼物也有非常自私的原因。其中之一是关于向你自己和周围的每个人展示你是一个什么样的人以及你是一个什么样的送礼者。所以展示你是一个有创意的送礼者很重要，因为如果我认为我是
a creative person, then I want to reinforce that by making sure that I make choices that are creative, even at the expense of a recipient. And I want to make that signal, again, to myself, but also to other people around me because it's just part of my identity. So you could argue that the height of uncreativity,
一个有创意的人，那么我想通过确保我做出有创意的选择来强化这一点，即使是以牺牲接收者为代价。我想向自己，也向周围的人发出这个信号，因为这只是我身份的一部分。所以你可以说，最缺乏创意的巅峰，
if you will, is to give the same gift over and over again. I understand researchers have actually studied how givers and recipients think of such gifts. What do they find, Jeff? Yeah, generally speaking, people don't like to do that, because it minimizes the sense that they feel creative. So if I give you a gift, I'm less likely to give the exact same gift to another friend, because it's going to make it seem like I'm less creative. Or even to the same friend. I mean, you wouldn't give me the same gift next year. Certainly right, even if it was a great gift, right?
如果你愿意的话，就是一次又一次地送同样的礼物。我了解到研究人员实际上已经研究了送礼者和接收者如何看待这样的礼物。他们发现了什么，杰夫？是的，总的来说，人们不喜欢这样做，因为它最小化了他们感到有创意的感觉。所以如果我给你一份礼物，我不太可能给另一个朋友送完全一样的礼物，因为它会让我看起来没那么有创意。甚至对同一个朋友也是如此。我的意思是，你明年不会送我同样的礼物。当然是对的，即使那是一份很棒的礼物，对吧？
So if I gave you a gift certificate to your favorite restaurant, I'm reluctant to do that again the next year, even though you'd probably really love that because there's a reason it's your favorite restaurant. So one of the things I think this conversation is highlighting for me, Jeff, is how gift giving can sometimes involve third parties, not just the giver and the recipient.
所以如果我给了你一张你最喜欢的餐厅的礼券，我明年很不情愿再这样做，尽管你可能真的会很喜欢，因为那成为你最喜欢的餐厅是有原因的。所以杰夫，我认为这次谈话对我来说突出的事情之一是，赠礼有时如何涉及第三方，而不仅仅是送礼者和接收者。
I'm thinking about settings where other people can see the gift that I have given, maybe at a baby shower or at a wedding, for example. So now my audience is not just the recipient, but all the other people who are going to be watching and evaluating my gift, right? Absolutely. And one of the consequences of that is, not only are you trying to give a gift at that point that's beneficial to the recipient,
我想到的是其他人可以看到我送出的礼物的场合，例如在迎婴派对或婚礼上。所以现在我的观众不仅是接收者，还有所有其他将要观看和评估我的礼物的人，对吧？绝对是。而这带来的后果之一是，在那一刻你不仅试图送出一份对接收者有益的礼物，
but you want to make sure that you're not one-upped. So an example of this in some of the work that I've done is, if I give you a bottle of wine, a really well-liked bottle of wine, and it's going to make you happy, but another friend gave you two bottles of wine, I look terrible, right? I look like I'm a cheapskate
而且你还要确保自己不会被比下去。我在我所做的一些工作中遇到的一个例子是，如果我送你一瓶葡萄酒，一瓶非常受欢迎的葡萄酒，它会让你快乐，但另一个朋友送了你两瓶葡萄酒，我看起来就很糟糕，对吧？我看起来像个吝啬鬼，
because I didn't give you enough. And so I'm very motivated to not be put in that position. And so some of the work we've looked at, so as you know, imagine if you had a scenario where you knew that this other person was gonna give two bottles of wine, would you spend more to say give three bottles of wine now? And people overwhelmingly say yes.
因为我送得不够多。所以我非常有动力不让自己处于那种境地。所以我们看了一些工作，你知道，想象一下，如果你有一个场景，你知道另一个人会送两瓶葡萄酒，你现在会花更多的钱去送三瓶葡萄酒吗？人们绝大多数回答是肯定的。
So you mentioned a second ago that one of the hidden motivations of gift giving is that it can serve as a means to acquire social approval or status. Do recipients attach the same store by expensive gifts as gift givers do? Not nearly as much as you would think. So one of the big findings in this literature is that, for example, the cost of a gift is not nearly as predictive in terms of happiness of the recipient as people tend to think. And so that translates to the prestige of the gift as well as, you know, the store that you're buying it from. People think, you know, the more you spend, the happier the
所以你刚才提到，赠礼的隐藏动机之一是它可以作为获取社会认可或地位的一种手段。接收者像送礼者那样看重昂贵的礼物吗？远没有你想象的那么多。所以这个文献中的一个重大发现是，例如，礼物的成本在接收者的快乐程度方面远不如人们想象的那样具有预测性。所以这也转化为礼物的声望以及你购买它的商店。人们认为，你知道，你花得越多，
person's going to be. And the evidence on that is very thin. the person's going to be and the evidence on that is very thin. Have you ever received a particularly expensive gift that made you you know either anxious about reciprocation or just sort of you know befuddled about why such an expensive gift was purchased? I've received expensive gifts. I'm very fortunate in that way but they've always been in context where reciprocation was not obvious. And this speaks to some of the norms that exist in gift giving that are very nuanced. So one thing that comes to mind is when my wife and I bought our new home, my parents actually bought us a retractable awning for our backyard, which is a really expensive
那个人就会越快乐。而关于这一点的证据非常薄弱。那个人会越快乐，而关于这一点的证据非常薄弱。你有没有收到过特别昂贵的礼物，让你感到回礼的焦虑，或者只是对为什么要买这么昂贵的礼物感到困惑？我收到过昂贵的礼物。我很幸运，但它们总是在回礼并不明显的情况下。这谈到了赠礼中存在的一些非常微妙的规范。所以我想起的一件事是，当我妻子和我买了新家时，我父母实际上给我们买了一个后院的伸缩遮阳篷，那是一份非常昂贵的
gift. That's a multi-thousand dollar gift. It's not something that you would normally get. There was no expectation that I would reciprocate that to my parents, in part because there's a norm that exists, which is that gifting down generations is very different than gifting up generations. And so that was a wonderful gift. We use this all the time, especially in the summer.
礼物。那是一份价值数千美元的礼物。这不是你通常会收到的东西。没有期望我会回礼给我父母，部分原因是存在一种规范，即向下代赠礼与向上代赠礼是非常不同的。所以那是一份很棒的礼物。我们经常使用它，特别是在夏天。
It provides a lot of shade, but there's really no expectation that I'm going to spend $10,000 on my parents. there's really no expectation that I'm gonna spend, you know, $10,000 on my parents. So we talked a second ago about how gift giving can be a form of status seeking. And one of these forms of status seeking can involve giving socially conscious gifts that highlight the giver's commitment to a virtuous cause, such as gifts to charity made in the recipient's name.
它提供了很多阴凉，但真的没有期望我会花1万美元在我的父母身上。真的没有期望我会花，你知道，1万美元在我的父母身上。所以我们刚才谈到了赠礼如何成为一种地位追求的形式。而这种地位追求的形式之一可能包括赠送强调送礼者对崇高事业承诺的社会意识礼物，例如以接收者的名义向慈善机构捐款。
I wanna play you a clip from the TV show Home Economics in which a character named Sarah chides her brother Connor for not prominently displaying the gifts that she has given him in the past. So I was looking around and I didn't see those Tibetan sound bowls. The ones I got you last Christmas.
我想给你播放一段来自电视剧《家政学》的片段，剧中一个叫莎拉的角色责备她的兄弟康纳没有显眼地展示她过去送给他的礼物。所以我环顾四周，没看到那些西藏颂钵。就是我去年圣诞节送你的那些。
Oh yeah, no, I never opened those. But it was a gift. You suck at gifts. You didn't know that? I've been trying to get her there. After you got me that novel about that girl in Peru who gets cancer... Fernandez's miracle. And that bracelet made by genius women... Indigenous women and it was an anklet.
哦，是的，不，我从来没打开过那些。但那是礼物。你送礼太烂了。你不知道吗？我一直试图让她达到那个水平。在你送我那本关于秘鲁女孩患癌症的小说之后……费尔南德斯的奇迹。还有那个天才女性制作的手镯……原住民女性，而且那是个脚链。
I just started tossing your gifts in the closet without unwrapping them. You never got me a puppy, did you? I think we're running low on sugar. Jeff, what has research found about giving socially conscious presents? I'm reluctant to answer your question because I think socially conscious gifts are for society a wonderful thing, but the research is pretty clear on this that recipients do not value them nearly as much as givers hope they would. So you can imagine scenarios where I might conceive of giving you a gift of value that
我只是开始把你的礼物扔进壁橱里，连包装都没拆。你从来没给我买过小狗，对吧？我想我们的糖快用完了。杰夫，研究发现关于赠送社会意识礼物有什么结果？我不愿意回答你的问题，因为我认为社会意识礼物对社会来说是一件美妙的事情，但研究对此非常明确，接收者并不像送礼者希望的那样看重它们。所以你可以想象一些场景，我可能会构思送你一份有价值的礼物，
let's say a hundred dollar value that is socially conscious, like a donation to a preferred charity or a material good that you would actually enjoy. And then the question is, are people enjoying those to the same degree? And the answer is firmly no, right? They would much prefer receiving something that will be useful to them than necessarily useful to society. Yeah. So in lots of ways, I think what we've seen
比如价值100美元的社会意识礼物，比如向首选慈善机构捐款，或者你会真正喜欢的物质商品。然后问题是，人们享受这些东西的程度一样吗？答案是坚决的否定，对吧？他们宁愿收到对他们有用的东西，也不一定是对社会有用的东西。是的。所以从很多方面来看，我想我们已经看到
is that gift givers can sometimes prioritize themselves in the gifts they give. So they want the recipient to be wowed. They want the gift to be better than other gifts. They want to show off their status and prestige. We haven't yet talked about the highest form of such selfishness. And here's a clip to demonstrate it from The Simpsons
送礼者有时会在他们送出的礼物中优先考虑自己。所以他们希望接收者感到惊叹。他们希望礼物比其他礼物更好。他们想炫耀自己的地位和声望。我们还没有谈到这种自私的最高形式。这里有一个来自《辛普森一家》的片段来演示它，
in which Homer gives his wife Marge a bowling ball. Hold on, hold on now. Your mother hasn't opened my present yet. Beauty, isn't she? Well, it's hard for me to judge since I've never bowled in my life. Well, if you don't want it, I know someone who does. So the bowling ball is inscribed with Homer's name. And you know, we laugh, Jeff, but we laugh because I think we all know how selfishness
其中荷马送给妻子玛吉一个保龄球。等等，等等。你妈妈还没打开我的礼物呢。漂亮，不是吗？嗯，这对我来说很难判断，因为我这辈子从来没打过保龄球。嗯，如果你不想要它，我知道有人想要。所以保龄球上刻着荷马的名字。杰夫，我们笑了，但我们笑是因为我想我们都知道自私
can sometimes be embedded in acts of seeming generosity. I think that's exactly right. I mean, I love that clip. It's just a wonderful example of such a perfectly selfish gift. And people do this. Now, I don't think they do it necessarily to the extent that The Simpsons is portraying, but there are more subtle ways to do this. So for example, if I have a product and I'm considering giving you a similar product, but if let's say higher quality, the classic example might be I have an older version of an iPhone and I'm considering buying you a newer version of an iPhone. I'm reluctant
有时是如何嵌入到看似慷慨的行为中的。我想那是完全正确的。我的意思是，我喜欢那个片段。这只是这样一个完美自私礼物的绝佳例子。人们确实这样做。现在，我不认为他们一定达到了《辛普森一家》所描绘的程度，但有更微妙的方法来做到这一点。所以例如，如果我有一个产品，我正在考虑送你一个类似的产品，但假设质量更高，经典的例子可能是，我有一个旧版本的iPhone，我正在考虑给你买一个新版本的iPhone。我很不情愿
to do that because I don't want your iPhone to be nicer than mine. Even though you might very well use that phone well, it might be something you'll enjoy a lot, I'm not going to do that. It's a selfish decision because I don't want you one-upping me. Gift-giving is as old as humankind, but human nature being what it is, people aren't generous just because they are kind and caring. Generosity can sometimes be exercised in ways that are profoundly selfish. When we come back, techniques to be better and to give better gifts. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain.
这样做，因为我不希望你的iPhone比我的好。尽管你很可能会很好地使用那部手机，它可能是你非常喜欢的东西，但我不会这样做。这是一个自私的决定，因为我不希望你比我强。赠礼行为与人类本身一样古老，但人性使然，人们并不总是因为善良和关怀而慷慨。慷慨有时可以以极其自私的方式行使。回来后，我们将探讨变得更好和送出更好礼物的技巧。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Gifts and gift exchangers are supposed to be about generosity, kindness, and caring. But below the surface of these prosocial goals, like complex psychological forces, many gift givers, consciously or unconsciously, prioritize their own needs over the preferences of recipients. At Carnegie Mellon University, Jeff Gallic studies the psychology of gift giving. He's found that in order to give good gifts, we need to get over ourselves. At Carnegie Mellon University, Jeff Galeck studies the psychology of gift-giving. He's found that in order to give good gifts, we need to get over ourselves. We
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。礼物和礼物交换应该是关于慷慨、善良和关怀的。但在这些亲社会目标的表面之下，隐藏着复杂的心理力量，许多送礼者，有意识或无意识地，将自己的需求置于接收者的偏好之上。在卡内基梅隆大学，杰夫·加利克研究赠礼心理学。他发现，为了送出好的礼物，我们需要克服自我。在卡内基梅隆大学，杰夫·加利克研究赠礼心理学。他发现，为了送出好的礼物，我们需要克服自我。我们
need to start by really trying to see the world from the perspective of recipients. Jeff, there's something of a conundrum here. We've all been gift givers and we've all also been gift receivers as well. So we know what it's like to receive a bad gift or a gift that's principally designed to stroke the egos of gift givers. And yet the moment we become gift givers, many of us forget the lessons that we have learned. Why do you think that happens? It's really difficult to learn. In large part because when we're in the role of a gift giver
需要从真正尝试从接收者的角度看世界开始。杰夫，这里有一个难题。我们都曾是送礼者，我们也都是礼物接收者。所以我们知道收到一份糟糕的礼物或一份主要旨在抚慰送礼者自尊心的礼物是什么感觉。然而，当我们成为送礼者时，我们许多人忘记了我们学到的教训。你认为为什么会发生这种情况？这真的很难学。很大程度上是因为当我们处于送礼者的角色
or the role of a gift recipient, we don't spontaneously choose to take the other perspective. This is a form of what we call focalism. We focus on the experience that we're in and we kind of neglect the alternative experience that might be out there, which would be the other perspective, the recipient or the giver.
或礼物接收者的角色时，我们不会自发地选择采取对方的视角。这是一种我们称之为“焦点主义”的形式。我们专注于我们所处的体验，而忽略了可能存在的另一种体验，即另一种视角，接收者或送礼者。
And so it's very hard to do that. And it's also hard to do that. And it's also a little bit disingenuous, I think, of me to just say, hey, everybody should be better, because I have the luxury of running experiments. I can learn what good practices are because I have random assignment as an experimenter. I have the ability to observe multiple worlds basically simultaneously, the case where someone is a giver and the case that someone is a receiver. You and I living in the real world as givers and receivers, we can't possibly have the opposite experience, right? If I give a gift, I cannot simultaneously operate
所以这很难做到。而且我认为，我只是说“嘿，每个人都应该做得更好”也有点虚伪，因为我有进行实验的奢侈。我可以学习什么是好的做法，因为我作为实验者有随机分配。我基本上有能力同时观察多个世界，即某人是送礼者的情况，以及某人是接收者的情况。你和我生活在现实世界中作为送礼者和接收者，我们不可能同时拥有相反的体验，对吧？如果我送出一份礼物，我不能同时操作
as a recipient with all the same constraints around me. It's just not, it's impossible. And so learning under that environment is very challenging because we're constantly being reinforced with whatever conceptions we have as a giver when we're in a giver state and the same when we're in a recipient state. I'm wondering how social norms
作为接收者，周围有所有相同的约束。这只是不可能的。所以在那样的环境下学习是非常具有挑战性的，因为当我们处于送礼者状态时，我们不断地被我们作为送礼者的任何概念所强化，当我们处于接收者状态时也是如此。我想知道社会规范
might also exacerbate this problem, Jeff. When you received a tub of popcorn from your relative, social norms told you, be polite, thank your relative. And so you thank the relative and the relative presumably goes away thinking, boy, I came up with a really clever gift. Instead of you telling the relative the truth, which is I have absolutely no idea why you gave this to me. Is the constraints that we have in terms of the way we talk about gifts one of the reasons in some ways that we don't learn what recipients actually like? I think that's absolutely correct. Giving good feedback is a wonderful thing to do
是否也可能加剧这个问题，杰夫。当你从亲戚那里收到那桶爆米花时，社会规范告诉你，要有礼貌，感谢你的亲戚。所以你感谢了亲戚，而亲戚大概走开了，心想，天哪，我想出了一个非常聪明的礼物。而不是你告诉亲戚真相，即我完全不知道你为什么要给我这个。我们谈论礼物的方式所受的约束，在某种程度上是我们不了解接收者真正喜欢什么的原因之一吗？我认为那是完全正确的。提供好的反馈是一件很棒的事情，
in many, many contexts, and there is a social taboo against giving proper feedback, meaning honest feedback, especially in the case where a gift fails. We're quick to tell somebody that we love their gifts, and that's great, we should reinforce those experiences, but we should also make sure that we tell people that the gift they gave is not ideal. The difficulty with that is that you're challenging
在许多许多情况下，而且存在一种反对提供适当反馈的社会禁忌，意味着诚实的反馈，特别是在礼物失败的情况下。我们很快就会告诉别人我们喜欢他们的礼物，这很好，我们应该强化那些体验，但我们也应该确保告诉人们他们送出的礼物并不理想。这样做的困难在于你正在挑战
a very established goal of gift giving, which is to make the other person happy. And if I now come back and I tell you, actually, you failed, you didn't make me happy. I'm really potentially insulting you. And so we're very reluctant to do that as a society. Yeah. So your research has identified ways that we can get outside ourselves and perhaps
一个非常既定的赠礼目标，即让对方快乐。如果我现在回来告诉你，实际上，你失败了，你没有让我快乐。我可能真的在侮辱你。所以作为一个社会，我们非常不情愿这样做。是的。所以你的研究已经确定了我们可以走出自我，也许
get closer to what recipients are looking for. And perhaps the first insight is to scale back our impulse to show that we can not only read the minds of gift recipients, but that we know things that they want that even they didn't know they wanted. In a perfect world, I would be able to look into your brain and find out what you're looking for, what you would hope to receive, and then I execute on that. Of course, we don't live in that world, right? I can't do that. And so as soon as I realize that that's not possible,
更接近接收者正在寻找的东西的方法。也许第一个见解是缩减我们展示不仅能读懂礼物接收者思想，而且知道他们想要什么，甚至连他们自己都不知道自己想要什么的冲动。在一个完美的世界里，我能够看进你的大脑，找出你在寻找什么，你希望收到什么，然后我执行它。当然，我们不生活在那个世界，对吧？我做不到。所以一旦我意识到那是不可能的，
the next best thing is just to talk to you and understand what your preferences are and to avoid some of the mistakes that we make by mismatching between what it is you want and what it is I think you want. If we can do that, it's not quite mind reading, but it's as close, I think, as we can get. I remember we talked some time ago
最好的办法就是和你交谈，了解你的偏好，并避免我们因你想要的和你认为你想要的之间的不匹配而犯的一些错误。如果我们能做到这一点，那就不完全是读心术，但我认为这是我们能做到的最接近的事情。我记得我们前段时间谈过
with psychologist Tessa West at NYU, and she studies how we read other people's minds, and her conclusion was really identical to yours, which is the best way to find out what's happening in someone else's mind is to ask them. I mean, I couldn't agree more, and I think, again, it speaks to the social norms that exist. We've built into our society, at least in our culture,
与纽约大学的心理学家泰莎·韦斯特，她研究我们如何读懂别人的思想，她的结论和你的一模一样，即找出别人脑子里在想什么的最好方法就是问他们。我的意思是，我完全同意，而且我认为，这再次说明了存在的社会规范。我们在我们的社会中，至少在我们的文化中，已经建立了
this belief that if I ask you what you want, I've undermined the entire gift-giving enterprise. And I think that's a catastrophic mistake that we're making, because all we're doing at that point is saying, I'm going to do my best to guess what you want, and more often than not, we get it wrong. And then you have the obligation to tell me you like it, regardless of whether you do or not. And then I'll never learn, and that's exactly right.
这种信念，即如果我问你想要什么，我就破坏了整个赠礼事业。我认为这是一个我们正在犯的灾难性错误，因为在那一点上我们所做的只是说，我会尽我所能去猜测你想要什么，而更多时候，我们猜错了。然后你有义务告诉我你喜欢它，不管你是否真的喜欢。然后我就永远学不会，这完全正确。
I understand that you and your wife have developed a method for acting on this research finding. What do you do, Jeff? Yeah, so my wife is also a social scientist, and so we're really good about trying to implement some of these things when we can. And the way that we've set up gift giving in our family, at least between my wife and myself, is that we have a Google Docs sheet that we share between the two of us, and whenever one of us has a desire for an item of some sort that kind of exceeds the minimum expense, we put it on there as a potential gift that we would love to receive at some point.
我了解到你和你的妻子已经开发出一种方法来实践这一研究发现。你是怎么做的，杰夫？是的，我妻子也是一位社会科学家，所以我们非常擅长在力所能及的情况下尝试实施其中的一些方法。我们家——至少我和我妻子之间——设定送礼方式的方法是，我们共享一个谷歌文档，每当我们中的任何一个人想要某种超过最低消费额的物品时，我们就会把它写在上面，作为我们希望在某个时候收到的潜在礼物。
And what's nice about that is when it's time for me to fulfill my obligation to say, give my wife a birthday present, I'm not racking my brain trying to figure out what one of a thousand possibilities would make her happy. She's already told me what's going to make her happy by having this list. And one of the nice benefits of the list beyond just knowing what she wants is it still maintains an element of surprise. Except the surprise doesn't come in the form of the object, it comes in the form of the timing of the object itself. So she might know that she wants item X, but she's not going to know that I'm going to give it to her on that particular birthday. And so I get the benefit of being what appears to be a thoughtful gift giver, and I get to be a little bit surprising because she doesn't know when she's going to get
这样做的好处是，当我要履行义务，比如给妻子送生日礼物时，我不用绞尽脑汁去想那一千种可能性中哪一种能让她开心。她已经通过这个清单告诉我什么能让她开心了。除了知道她想要什么之外，这个清单还有一个好处，那就是它仍然保持了一种惊喜感。只不过惊喜不是以物品的形式出现，而是以物品到来的时间形式出现。所以她可能知道她想要某样东西，但她不知道我会在那个特定的生日送给她。所以我既能表现得像个贴心的送礼者，又能制造一点惊喜，因为她不知道她什么时候会收到
it, and she gets something that she genuinely wants. So everybody wins in that context, it's been working for us for 12 years now of our marriage and we'll keep going as long as we can. Have you found that when you get a gift that you have put on this Google Doc, this shared Google Doc, that in some ways you're less enthused about it than if the gift was something that you hadn't thought about, that your wife somehow stumbled on by accident? No, quite the opposite. I'm always overjoyed when I get exactly what it is that I want. And maybe that's a function of my personality. I'm very particular when it comes to things. I want that model and that version with that feature set for
它，而且她能得到她真正想要的东西。所以在这种情况下，每个人都是赢家。我们结婚12年来一直这样做，只要可以，我们会一直坚持下去。你有没有发现，当你收到你放在这个谷歌文档——这个共享谷歌文档——里的礼物时，在某种程度上，你对它的热情是否不如收到你没想过、你妻子偶然发现的礼物时那么高？不，恰恰相反。当我得到我真正想要的东西时，我总是欣喜若狂。也许这是我性格使然。在对待事物时，我非常挑剔。我想要那个型号、那个版本、带有那套功能的
whatever it is that I'm dealing with. And it would be ridiculous for me to expect anyone to know what those idiosyncratic preferences would be. And so I want to provide that to her. I want to be able to tell her, you know, if you're gonna get me something in this product category, that's the one I want, not the other options. They're gonna make me unhappy because now I'm stuck with those. Yeah. Because I can't go and replace them with the one I actually want because that would probably make my wife really upset if I did that. Yeah. Have you had a gift that you put on this sort of internal registry I guess
无论我处理的是什么。如果我指望别人知道那些独特的偏好，那太荒谬了。所以我希望能提供给她。我希望能告诉她，你知道，如果你要在这一产品类别中给我买东西，那就是我想要的，而不是其他选择。那些会让我不开心，因为现在我被它们困住了。是的。因为我不能去把它们换成我真正想要的那个，如果我那样做，可能会让我妻子非常生气。是的。你有没有收到过你放在这种内部注册表里的礼物，我想
that you really loved? So I would say the best gift that I've received in a long time is a gift that my wife gave me several years ago. I'm really into coffee and she gave me a pretty fancy espresso machine and again it hit every mark. It is something that I explicitly wanted. It was the exact model of the thing that I wanted. It's something that I use every single day, multiple times every day, in fact. It brings me a ton of joy because it makes great coffee.
是你真正喜欢的？我想说，我很久以来收到的最好的礼物是我妻子几年前送给我的。我非常喜欢咖啡，她送了我一台相当高档的浓缩咖啡机，同样，它完全符合我的要求。这是我明确想要的东西。它正是我想要的那个型号。事实上，这是我每天都在使用，而且每天使用多次的东西。它给我带来了巨大的快乐，因为它能做出很棒的咖啡。
And on top of everything, every single time I use it, I am genuinely reminded of her and of the generosity that she had in giving me that gift. And so it is not in any way undermining the quality of the gift. It's doing the exact opposite. I understand there's also been research on the relative value of gifts that involve material things and gifts involving experiences. Tell me a little bit about this research, Jeff. Yeah, there's been a fair bit of work in psychology, generally, looking at the difference between experiences
最重要的是，每次我使用它时，我都会真切地想起她，想起她送我这份礼物时的慷慨。所以这绝不会削弱礼物的质量。恰恰相反。我了解到，关于涉及物质的东西和涉及体验的礼物的相对价值，也有过相关研究。跟我谈谈这项研究吧，杰夫。是的，心理学界通常有相当多的研究，着眼于体验
and material possessions, just outside of the world of gift giving. And what you tend to find in that work is that all else being equal, if you fix things on price, experiences tend to bring more joy to people. And that plays out exactly in gift giving as well. The challenge though,
和物质财富之间的区别，这不仅仅是在送礼的世界里。你在这些研究中往往会发现，在其他条件相同的情况下，如果你固定价格，体验往往会给人们带来更多的快乐。这一点在送礼中也完全适用。然而，挑战在于
is that gift givers don't understand and appreciate this. So gift givers prefer to give material possessions over experiences, again, all else being equal, but recipients prefer the opposite. And so there's this disconnect where you'd be much better off giving an experiential gift most of the time and recipients would be much happier with that. But gift givers again, just like the other examples,
送礼者并不理解和欣赏这一点。所以，在其他条件相同的情况下，送礼者更喜欢送物质财富而不是体验，但接受者却更喜欢相反的。所以这里存在一种脱节，大多数情况下，送体验类礼物会好得多，接受者也会更开心。但送礼者，就像其他例子一样，
they fail to learn that this is something that's valuable. I wondered if this partly stems from the problem we discussed earlier, which is that givers really care about the wow factor in gifts. And so if you hand someone, you know, tickets to a concert, for example, the wow might come when the person goes to the concert, not at the point at which the tickets are given. Whereas if you give something that's, you know, tickets to a concert, for example, the wow might come when the person goes to the concert, not at the point at which the tickets are given. Whereas if you give something that's a, you know,
他们没能认识到这是有价值的。我想知道这是否部分源于我们之前讨论的问题，即送礼者非常在意礼物的“惊艳感”。所以，如果你给某人，比如音乐会门票，惊艳感可能出现在那个人去听音乐会的时候，而不是送出票的那一刻。而如果你送的是，你知道，
really big, gaudy, you know, bauble that can be wrapped in lots of paper, then the wow factor is sort of much sharper at the point at which the gift is being given. Do you think that's connected? I think that's probably part of what's going on there. I think what you wind up finding in an experience is that two things can happen. One is the experience brings people closer together, but like you point out, that might be later on in time, so it doesn't really manifest in the moment. But then even when it's not bringing people together,
非常大、花哨的、可以用很多纸包装的小玩意儿，那么在送出礼物的那一刻，惊艳感会更强烈。你认为这有联系吗？我想这可能就是原因的一部分。我认为你最终会发现，在体验中，两件事可能会发生。一是体验让人们走得更近，但正如你指出的，那可能是在以后的时间里，所以它并没有真正体现在当下。但即使它没有让人们走得更近，
like if I give you tickets to a show that I don't plan to go with you to, that still has more utility and more value for you. So yes, I agree completely. You're failing to put a smile on the person's face at the moment of exchange, but you're potentially providing a very valuable experience down the road.
比如我给你演出门票，但我并不打算和你一起去，这对你来说仍然有更多的效用和价值。所以是的，我完全同意。你在交换的那一刻没能让对方脸上露出笑容，但你可能在未来提供了一次非常有价值的体验。
Have you put this advice to life in your own life? Do you tend to give more experiential gifts now? Almost exclusively. Yeah, I mean, with the exception of my kids who just want more toys, I almost exclusively do gifts So my wife her and I our anniversary is coming up and we collectively decided that rather than exchange material gifts We're gonna take a day off of work and spend the day at a nice spa getting massages and then have a really nice dinner afterwards
你是否在自己的生活中实践过这些建议？你现在是否倾向于送更多的体验类礼物？几乎全是。是的，除了我的孩子们，他们只想要更多的玩具，我几乎只送体验类礼物。所以我和我妻子，我们的结婚纪念日快到了，我们共同决定，与其交换物质礼物，不如请一天假，在一家不错的温泉会所度过一天，做做按摩，然后去吃顿非常好的晚餐。
And both of us cannot wait to do that. There's no reservation about Not receiving something physical or tangible. We really prefer that. And I try to live that as much as I can. Have you tried to communicate to other people, like your parents, that you actually prefer experiential gifts rather than material gifts? Very much so. So my parents were a tough nut to crack.
我们俩都迫不及待地想这样做。对于没有收到实物或有形的东西，我们没有任何保留。我们真的更喜欢那样。我尽量尽可能地去实践这一点。你有没有尝试过向其他人，比如你的父母，传达你其实更喜欢体验类礼物而不是物质礼物？非常明确地传达过。所以我的父母是块难啃的骨头。
They like giving material possessions. But eventually I've convinced them. And the best gift that they continuously give me is the gift of babysitting. So, my parents don't live in the same city as us. They come in every once in a while to see their grandkids. And they've now been offering more than anything else as a gift for a birthday or something else
他们喜欢送物质财富。但最终我说服了他们。他们不断送给我的最好的礼物就是帮忙照看孩子。所以，我的父母不住在同一个城市。他们偶尔会来看看孙子孙女。他们现在提供的作为生日或其他场合的礼物，比任何其他东西都多，
to watch the kids for a couple of days to let me and my wife go off and travel somewhere and that's there's really nothing better that I could possibly have that would be a possession than that gift so I'm so grateful for it. I understand that givers often avoid presents that have sentimental value because these presents seem less impressive than something that costs a lot of money. How do sentimental gifts sit with recipients, Jeff? Yeah, so sentimental gifts are gifts
那就是帮我照看孩子几天，让我和妻子能出去旅行，这真的没有什么比这份礼物更好的了，比任何物质财富都好，所以我非常感激。我了解到，送礼者往往会避免送有纪念价值的礼物，因为这些礼物看起来不如花很多钱的东西令人印象深刻。杰夫，接受者对纪念性礼物有什么看法？是的，所以纪念性礼物是
that recipients love to have. Because again, if you think about what the function of a gift could be, it is to bring people together. And a gift that has sentimental value, so imagine a photograph of a time that you spent with a friend, or even something as rudimentary as a token, like a shell that you picked up on a beach
是收礼人所钟爱的。因为再说一次，如果你思考礼物的意义，它其实是为了拉近人与人之间的距离。一份具有情感价值的礼物，比如一张你和朋友共度时光的照片，甚至是一个像在海滩上捡到的贝壳那样简单的信物，
after walking with somebody down it as a gift. They have very little material value, right, from a dollar perspective, but they're so special and they act as such a reminder of the relationship that they're very valuable to recipients. Unfortunately, much like some of these other examples, gift-givers get that wrong. And part of that is gift-givers tend to be risk-averse
在和某人散步后作为礼物送出。从金钱角度来看，它们几乎没有什么物质价值，但它们非常特别，是这段关系的见证，因此对收礼人来说非常有价值。遗憾的是，就像其他一些例子一样，送礼人往往会搞错。部分原因是送礼人往往倾向于规避风险，
when they give gifts. And so if I know for a fact that if I get you a jersey from a football player that you're a big fan of, I know you're gonna like that. And so I'm more likely to give you that low-risk gift than the high-risk sentimental gift where I'm just not sure if that's gonna be enjoyable, even though what we find in research is that those sentimental gifts are very, very
在送礼时。如果我确定送你一件你非常喜欢的足球运动员的球衣，我知道你会喜欢。所以我更倾向于送这种低风险的礼物，而不是那种我不确定你是否会喜欢的、高风险的情感类礼物，尽管我们的研究发现，那些情感类礼物非常、非常
well received, often much more so than the sure thing. I understand you once took a trip to Antarctica with your wife and she gave you a wonderful gift afterwards. Tell me about it, Jeff. So this was our our baby moon, I think people call it. This is the last big trip that we took before we had our first child. And upon returning, I had no expectation of this at all, but she got me this beautiful poster, which was handcrafted by an artisan that says,
受欢迎，通常比那些“稳妥”的礼物更受欢迎。我听说你曾经和妻子去过南极洲，之后她送了你一份很棒的礼物。跟我说说吧，杰夫。那是我们的“蜜月宝宝”之旅，我想人们是这么叫的。这是我们在生第一个孩子之前进行的最后一次大旅行。回来后，我完全没有预料到，但她送了我一张精美的海报，是一位工匠手工制作的，上面写着，
I love you from here to Antarctica. And the lettering is made up of all the places that we visited on that trip. And so the trip was, you know, it's a trip of a lifetime. It's an absolutely incredible trip to go on. And it's made all the more special that I shared it with my wife. And now I have this amazing memento that I look at.
“我爱你，从这里到南极洲”。上面的文字是由我们在那次旅行中去过的所有地方的名字组成的。那次旅行，你知道，是一生难忘的旅行。那是一次绝对不可思议的旅行。而我和妻子共同分享了这段经历，让它变得更加特别。现在我有了这个很棒的纪念品，我看着它，
It's hanging up very prominently in our home. And every time I pass it and I notice it, it's a reminder of that wonderful experience and the relationship that I have with her. So the cost of that was probably very low. I mean, I had to imagine it was $50 or so. But the meaningfulness of it is off the charts. I understand that you have also reciprocated
它非常显眼地挂在我们家里。每次我经过并注意到它，它都会提醒我那段美好的经历以及我和她之间的关系。所以它的成本可能非常低。我的意思是，我猜大概也就50美元左右。但它的意义却是无法估量的。我听说你也回赠了
and given your wife sentimental gifts. Absolutely. So one that comes to mind is when our daughter was born, that was our first child, I had an artisan craft a necklace with three pendants on it and each pendant had one of our names on it. So it was kind of to signify our family. And again, it wasn't the most valuable gift from a monetary perspective,
给你的妻子情感类礼物。当然。我想到的一件是我们的女儿出生时，那是我们的第一个孩子，我请一位工匠制作了一条项链，上面有三个吊坠，每个吊坠上都有我们其中一个人的名字。这算是象征我们的家庭。再说一次，从金钱角度来看，它不是最昂贵的礼物，
but my wife really cherished it. And then when our son was born a few years later, I had the same artisan craft a fourth pendant with his name on it. And so now she has this necklace commemorating our family. And I know that she loves that necklace quite a bit. And again, it's not because it's got, you know, fancy diamonds or rubies in it or anything like that, far from it. It's a pretty plain necklace, but the sentiment is so very strong.
但我妻子非常珍惜它。几年后我们的儿子出生时，我请同一位工匠制作了第四个吊坠，上面刻着他的名字。所以现在她有了这条纪念我们家庭的项链。我知道她非常喜欢这条项链。再说一次，并不是因为它上面有昂贵的钻石或红宝石之类的东西，恰恰相反。它是一条很朴素的项链，但其中的情感却非常强烈。
One of the important conventions in gift giving is that we often give gifts on important occasions, birthdays, Christmas, Valentine's Day. Tell me what research has found about breaking those conventions and giving gifts at other times of the year. Yeah, this is probably my all-time favorite and largest recommendation that I can give to anyone listening to this program, which is that if you're going to give a gift, do it what I like to say, on a random Tuesday. The value that people get when they receive gifts on non-occasions, so not your birthday, not Christmas, not some
送礼的一个重要惯例是，我们通常在重要的场合送礼，比如生日、圣诞节、情人节。请告诉我研究发现关于打破这些惯例并在一年中的其他时间送礼有什么发现。是的，这可能是我能给所有听众的最喜欢、也是最重要的建议，那就是如果你要送礼物，就像我常说的，选在一个普通的周二。人们在非节日收到礼物时所获得的价值，也就是不是在你的生日、圣诞节或其他
other holiday, that value is so much higher on a random Tuesday. And that is because they have no expectations. On a birthday, you know that the people around you are probably going to get you gifts. And so your expectations are actually reasonably high for the quality of that gift to meet or exceed those expectations. But on a random Tuesday, you're just going through your day enjoying your life. There's no expectation of anything.
其他节日时，那种价值在普通的周二要高得多。这是因为他们没有任何期待。在生日那天，你知道周围的人可能会送你礼物。所以你对礼物质量的期望实际上相当高，希望它能达到或超过这些期望。但在一个普通的周二，你只是在过着你的日常生活，享受着你的生活。没有任何期待。
And so if someone who cares about you gives you a gift, even a very low value one, from a monetary perspective, you beam, right? And you could imagine it's not that hard to think about examples of this, right? a very low value one from a monetary perspective, you beam. You could imagine it's not that hard to think about examples of this. Receiving flowers on a birthday is great. Receiving flowers on a Valentine's Day, that's great too. But receiving flowers from a partner on a random Tuesday, that's amazing.
所以如果一个关心你的人送你一份礼物，即使从金钱角度来看价值很低，你也会笑逐颜开，对吧？你可以想象，想到这样的例子并不难，对吧？即使从金钱角度来看价值很低，你也会笑逐颜开。在生日收到鲜花很棒。在情人节收到鲜花也很棒。但如果在普通的周二收到伴侣送的鲜花，那真是太棒了。
That is an opportunity to show that person you care about them, not just when you're supposed to care about them on the days we've been told to care, but all the time. And so we find that the utility and the value that receivers get on these non-occasion gifts is just much, much higher than it is for gifts that they receive for special occasions. I suppose that one of the implications of this
这是一个向对方展示你在乎他们的机会，不仅仅是在被告知应该在乎的日子里，而是在任何时候。因此，我们发现收礼人在这些非节日礼物中获得的效用和价值，远高于他们在特殊场合收到的礼物。我想这意味着，
is that when you have an impulse of generosity towards someone, instead of saying, you know, oh, this is a good idea, I'm going to save it for their next birthday, is just to give them the gift right away. I think that's exactly right. Now, I think there are probably constraints around that. Some things are just not financially feasible, but that's the beauty of these non-occasion gifts. It does not take a lot of money to make somebody happy because again their expectations at that moment are zero.
当你对某人产生慷慨的冲动时，与其说“哦，这是个好主意，我要留到他们下次生日再送”，不如直接把礼物送给他们。我认为这完全正确。现在，我认为这可能存在一些限制。有些事情在经济上是不可行的，但这就是这些非节日礼物的魅力所在。不需要花很多钱就能让某人开心，因为再说一次，他们在那一刻的期望值为零。
And so even a token gift worth a few dollars can mean a tremendous amount and often even more than a comparably expensive gift on an occasion. I understand that you yourself were given an unexpected gift by a running buddy. Tell me that story, Jeff. Friendships, new friendships when you're an adult are difficult. I'm sure I'm not the only person who thinks that. And so when you find somebody who you connect with, I think it's really important to foster that relationship. And I don't think I realized that quite as much until this particular friend.
所以即使是一份价值几美元的象征性礼物，也可能意义重大，甚至往往比在节日送出的昂贵礼物更有意义。我听说你自己也收到过一位跑步伙伴送的意外礼物。跟我讲讲那个故事吧，杰夫。友谊，成年后的新友谊很难建立。我相信我不是唯一一个这么想的人。所以当你找到一个有共鸣的人时，我认为培养这种关系非常重要。在遇到这位朋友之前，我并没有意识到这一点。
I was socializing with him at an event that had nothing to do with my birthday. I don't like to make a big deal out of that. And he learned spontaneously that it happened to be my birthday. And he gave me a survival axe. What is a survival axe? Imagine like a hand axe, but you could unscrew the bottom and it has a compass in it and some paracord
我在一个与我生日无关的活动上与他社交。我不喜欢把生日搞得大张旗鼓。他自发地得知那天正好是我的生日。他送了我一把生存斧。什么是生存斧？想象一下手斧，但你可以拧开底部，里面有一个指南针和一些伞绳，
and you can convert it into a shovel. And it's the kind of thing where if you were stuck in the middle of a zombie apocalypse, I guess you could survive with it. I mean, he knows I'm an outdoorsy person. He knows I enjoy camping. So I guess it's not completely out of context there, but I had no expectation of anything. And so he gave me this gift, I think in part because he cared
你还可以把它变成一把铲子。这东西就是那种如果你被困在僵尸末日中，我想你可以用它生存下来。我的意思是，他知道我是一个户外运动爱好者。他知道我喜欢露营。所以我想这并不是完全不合时宜，但我没有任何期待。所以他送了我这份礼物，我想部分是因为他关心
about me and that's great, but in part probably strategically because it is a way to in fact create connection with somebody. And again, the reason that gift landed so well with me at least is because I didn't expect it. If this was a birthday party that I had invited him to, I would expect him to have a gift perhaps, right, as many birthday parties do.
我，这很好，但部分可能也是出于策略，因为这确实是一种与人建立联系的方式。再说一次，那份礼物之所以让我感觉那么好，至少是因为我没有预料到。如果这是一个我邀请他参加的生日派对，我可能会期待他带一份礼物，对吧，就像许多生日派对那样。
But this was just a random day that happened to be my birthday. And so he did that, I think, out of genuine generosity and genuine care for the relationship. So in many ways, Jeff, I think what I'm hearing is that being a good gift giver really means putting yourself second and putting the recipient first.
但这只是一个碰巧是我生日的普通日子。所以我想他是出于真诚的慷慨和对这段关系的真诚关心才这么做的。所以杰夫，在很多方面，我想我听到的是，做一个好的送礼人真正意味着要把自己放在第二位，把收礼人放在第一位。
And perhaps the ultimate form of selfless gift giving is the anonymous gift. I understand that you've been part of a rather unusual gift exchange for a number of years now. Can you tell me about it, Jeff? So the website Reddit, which is a popular social media platform,
也许无私送礼的终极形式是匿名送礼。我听说你多年来一直参与一个相当不寻常的礼物交换活动。能跟我说说吗，杰夫？所以Reddit网站，一个流行的社交媒体平台，
had for years now something called the Reddit gift exchange. And it started with an exchange around Christmas. This was the Secret Santa gift exchange. And it was quite an impressive around Christmas, this was the Secret Santa gift exchange. And it was quite an impressive feat. So at the height of it, I think they had millions of people logging into this platform, committing to give a gift to a random stranger who they didn't know much about for the holidays.
多年来一直有一个叫Reddit礼物交换的活动。它始于圣诞节前后的交换。这就是“秘密圣诞老人”礼物交换。这是一个相当令人印象深刻的壮举。在鼎盛时期，我想他们有数百万人登录这个平台，承诺在节日期间给一个他们不太了解的陌生人送礼物。
And they would also then expect to receive a gift, though not from the same person. And it's usually done with very minimal information. There's a form that people fill out about their preferences and their desires. And I might tell you my age and my gender and maybe some of my hobbies and things of that sort. And there's also an expectation set about the expense that people should undertake. So if I remember correctly, the suggested spending amount was about $20 plus shipping. And it was wonderful. I did it for years.
他们也会期待收到一份礼物，尽管不是来自同一个人。这通常是在信息非常少的情况下完成的。人们会填写一份关于他们的偏好和愿望的表格。我可能会告诉你我的年龄、性别，也许还有我的一些爱好之类的东西。而且对于人们应该花费的金额也有一个预期的设定。如果我没记错的话，建议的消费金额大约是20美元加上运费。这太棒了。我做了好几年。
I never received a truly amazing gift, to be perfectly honest. They were all fairly mundane, but it was still really fun because it's this moment where a random stranger from somewhere else in the world is sending me something for no reason at all, right? There's no expectation of our simplicity. There's no expectation that I'll ever even really thank them
老实说，我从来没有收到过真正令人惊叹的礼物。它们都很普通，但仍然非常有趣，因为这是一个来自世界其他地方的陌生人无缘无故地给我寄东西的时刻，对吧？没有对我们简单性的期待。甚至没有期待我真的会感谢他们，
other than in some anonymous fashion. And then they still continue giving the next year. I just think that's wonderful. People really aren't doing this out of obligation. They're doing this because it's just a nice thing to do around the holidays. I understand that you're a fan of the O. Henry short story, The Gift of the Magi. How does that story speak to your work, Jeff? So the story, put very simply, is that a husband and wife who don't have a lot of wealth are
除了以某种匿名的方式。然后他们第二年还会继续送。我只是觉得这太棒了。人们真的不是出于义务才这样做。他们这样做是因为在节日期间做一件好事。我听说你是欧·亨利短篇小说《麦琪的礼物》的粉丝。那个故事对你的工作有什么启发吗，杰夫？简单来说，这个故事讲的是一对并不富裕的夫妻，
looking to give one another a holiday gift around the Christmas time. And what we know in the story is that the husband really loves his watch and the wife really loves her hair. And so in thinking about what gifts to give to one another, the wife winds up cutting off her hair to sell it so that she can get a chain for her husband's watch, while the husband actually sells the watch to get a comb or a brush for the wife.
在圣诞节期间想要给对方送一份节日礼物。我们知道故事里丈夫非常爱他的手表，妻子非常爱她的头发。所以在考虑送什么礼物给对方时，妻子最终剪掉了她的头发卖掉，以便为丈夫的手表买一条表链，而丈夫则卖掉了手表为妻子买了一把梳子或刷子。
And so the irony there of course is that neither one of them can use the gifts they gave, but it was truly a selfless decision to give away their prized possession so that their partner can actually have something valuable. And I think it's a wonderful sentiment. It speaks to a lot of people. But I think the major problem with that story is that the whole thing could have been avoided
所以其中的讽刺之处当然是，他们两个人都无法使用他们送出的礼物，但这确实是一个无私的决定，为了让对方能拥有真正有价值的东西而放弃了自己珍视的财产。我认为这是一种美妙的情感。它触动了很多人。但我认为那个故事的主要问题在于，这一切本可以避免，
had they just talked to one another. If they had... That's it. In all seriousness, right, if the wife had asked the husband what he was hoping to receive and the husband had asked the wife the same, they wouldn't have been in a position of having two useless items at the end of this and at losing their most precious possessions. And so this really speaks to a recommendation that I always give, which is just ask, right? If you just talk to another human being and ask them what
如果他们只是互相沟通的话。如果他们……就是这样。说真的，如果妻子问丈夫他希望收到什么，丈夫也问妻子同样的问题，他们就不会陷入最后得到两件无用之物并失去最珍贵财产的境地。所以这确实印证了我总是给出的一个建议，那就是直接问，对吧？如果你只是和另一个人交谈并问他们
it is that might make them happy in terms of a gift context, you're just almost always better off. Jeff Gallick is a marketing researcher at Carnegie Mellon University. Jeff, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was my pleasure. Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
在礼物方面什么能让他们开心，你几乎总是会做得更好。杰夫·加利克是卡内基梅隆大学的市场营销研究员。杰夫，非常感谢你今天参加我们的《隐藏的大脑》节目。这是我的荣幸。墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you're looking for a holiday gift for a fellow Hidden Brain fan in your life, we have two ideas to share with you. You can now give a gift subscription to Hidden Brain Plus. Just follow the link we've included in the show notes for today's episode. Or if material gifts are more your style, bar our chat with Jeff Gallick, go to shop.hiddenbrain.org to find Hiddenbrain
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你正在为你生活中的另一位《隐藏的大脑》粉丝寻找节日礼物，我们有两个想法可以分享。你现在可以赠送一份《隐藏的大脑Plus》的订阅。只需点击我们在今天节目说明中提供的链接即可。或者，如果物质礼物更符合你的风格，在与杰夫·加利克的聊天之后，请访问shop.hiddenbrain.org查找Hiddenbrain
t-shirts, mugs, stickers and more. That site again is shop.hiddenbrain.org. From all of us at Hidden Brain, happy holidays and we really appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
T恤、马克杯、贴纸等等。网站地址再次重申是shop.hiddenbrain.org。我们《隐藏的大脑》全体成员祝大家节日快乐，我们非常感谢你们的支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。